في ايران ايضا مشاهدينا وكانه ممنهج
ومقصود تكررت حادثه تسليم الطالبات في
مدارس بالعاصمه طهران هذه الحادثه التي
سنتابعها الان تاتي بعد سلسله هجمات
مماثله في مناطق ايرانيه اخرى نسبت الى
افراد يعرضون تعليم الفتيات وفق ما افادت
وسيله اعلام محليه وكاله تسنيم الايرانيه
افادت بتسميم عدد معين من التلميذات في
مدرسه خيام للبنات في مدينه برديس الواقعه
في محافظه طهران واضافت انه حتى الان نقلت
35 تلميذه الى المستشفى وان اجهزه الطوارئ
موجوده في المدرسه للسيطره على الوضع
لافته ان المصابات هن بخير ايضا منذ
نوفمبر الماضي تحدثت وسائل الاعلام عن
تصميم مئات الفتيات اللواتي لا تتجاوز
اعمارهن عشره اعوام في مدارس مدينه
بوسط ايران ونقل بعضهن الى المستشفى لوقت
قصير وزاره الصحه قالت الاحد ان بعض
الافراد يسعون عبر ذلك الى اغلاق كل
المدارس وخصوصا مدارس الفتيات على غرار
طبعا ما تفعله طالبان في افغانستان هذه
القضيه اثارت غضبا كبيرا داخليا في ايران
كما ندد البعض بصمت السلطات عن العدد
المتزايد من المدارس التي شهدت هذه
الظاهره
[موسيقى]
كل عمرها